going skiing or snowboarding grab these
apps for a great day on the slopes
starting with tricks know the app is a
super comprehensive guide to various
popular skiing and snowboarding resorts
and also lets you track your activity
find chair lifts and clock how much time
you're spending on the mountain
another worthwhile download is epic mix
the app offers snow conditions and
tracks your activity while also offering
features like challenges and it's also
available at a handful of popular
resorts having a hard time finding
friends on the mountain try snow cruise
ski and snowboard tracking app if you
need help keeping track of and chatting
with your friends on the slopes its
killer for organizing that last run and
after slope ski drinks more general snow
reports can come in use when you're out
in the elements though REI snow report
gives you up-to-date information on
conditions so you can decide whether
it's worth sucking up the car and
hitting the slopes with your board or
skis or maybe if the day is better
suited for sledding or snowshoeing open
snow also offers snow forecasts and
specifically tells you whether it's a
good day for skiing or snowboarding open
snow even has webcams to show you
exactly what conditions look like and
both apps let you set alerts so you can
get real-time reports on when it's time
to hit the road and head to the
mountains